[Music]
hi
i'm toby and welcome back to the joy of
mathematics
it's been a minute since i filmed one of
these but i'm so glad that you're
joining me again today
for a relaxing journey through
mathematics i'm going to run some things
across the bottom of the screen
that we will come to understand in this
video but mostly we will be learning how
to escape
from reality
some people do this through drawing
painting
reading or playing video games but we
are going to get a private tour
of an imaginary world with the help of
my
imaginary friends before i introduce you
let me tell you a story when i was six
years old
i remember a kid in my class at school
saying that there were secret numbers
that only he knew about he said that the
teacher
had told him about them after class that
they were less than zero
and called negative numbers
i was doubtful i hadn't ever heard of
such things
i thought that if it was true then the
teacher surely would have told all of us
maybe i felt a little hurt that she had
picked a favorite student
or that i was missing out on something
perhaps that's why i still
remember all these years later
of course i eventually found out that
negative numbers were real
but i had another similar experience
several years later
in high school math class we had a
relief teacher one day
i think it was the careers counsellor he
spent the start of the hour
following our teacher's lesson plan but
towards the end
veered far enough of course that he said
have you guys heard of imaginary numbers
we hadn't with animated strokes he drew
a large axis
and labelled one real and the other
imaginary
after that class i felt pretty mind
blown
maybe i was yet to really understand
them
but that was the first i heard of these
mysterious new numbers
i had again experienced my view of
numbers being expanded
a long time later i would realize that
negative numbers and imaginary numbers
are in fact similar in the way that they
extend
mathematics they are both somewhat
intangible ideas
that prove to be useful where the
negatives come from asking
what one minus two might equal the
imaginary unit i
comes from asking what the square root
of -1
might be if it existed
now it's in the best interests of you
and i to acknowledge that we live
in the real world and our actions have
real consequences
so we should try to be nice to each
other
i will introduce you to my imaginary
friends now
and whilst this isn't a popularity
contest we will want to keep track of
how many
imaginary friends we have at the moment
we haven't met any
so we can write i
to the zero and it's one of those quirky
little mathematical facts
that anything to the power of zero is
equal to one
this solution is our passport and since
one is a real number
we're not going anywhere and we have to
stay out here
in the real world but meet my first
imaginary friend ignacio
with him we have i to the one
which is equal to i
so with our first friend we can now
travel
from the real world to the imaginary
world
it's wonderful in here but now i'm
trapped
how can i go back to reality my second
imaginary friend
iguana can help with two imaginary
friends
we have negative one
i'm back in the real world but this is
the negative real world
and it's so sad out here i could get
help from a real friend who is negative
such as minus one but there's not really
anyone out here
i could instead get help from two more
imaginary friends
with three imaginary friends in total we
are taken back to the imaginary world
but we end up being underground
and a fourth imaginary friend in total
will bring us back
out to the positive real world right
where we started
this is all you need to know to travel
between
our world and the imaginary world
we can show our story on a map where
we're jumping between the points
one i minus one and minus i
and that is because multiplying by i
is a rotation of 90 degrees
if the friends we met had been a gang of
negative numbers
then we would have toggled between one
and minus one
this flipping shows that multiplying by
minus one
is a rotation of one hundred and eighty
degrees
but an imaginary friend takes us to a
pit stop
in between to have a timeout from
reality
because multiplying by i is a rotation
of 90 degrees
then if we do it twice we get to
negative 1
and if we do it four times we get back
where we started
we could of course go the other way as
well we would see a clockwise rotation
of 90 degrees
if we multiplied by minus i this ability
to multiply and move around in a circle
is what makes imaginary numbers so good
at
modeling things that are circular in
nature or that rotate
and despite the name they are not
imaginary at all
some people just have trouble seeing
them and whether you want to believe
in imaginary numbers or not they're
right there
a second dimension to every number
it says mind-blowing as decimals or
irrationals would have been
to early mathematicians some never got
to know
there were numbers in between one and
two
larger friends such as 2i 3i and 4i
allow us to go anywhere on these axes
but what about the rest of the plane
well
yes we can travel anywhere we like it's
just a little bit more complicated
this is the complex plane after all
in the rest of this region we need two
parts
a real part and an imaginary part
to explain where we are with one foot in
each door
here at one plus i we are halfway
between worlds a rotation of 45 degrees
let's see a use for multiplying complex
numbers
say you go for a walk in the forest but
you end up getting a little lost
at first you walk along the path laid
out
in the direction of eight plus two i
but you realize this isn't right and you
want to change your track
by 45 degrees how would you work this
out
well normally you could do some
trigonometry some sine and cosine
maybe you need to carry a protractor
with you to work out the angles
or you can multiply 8 plus 2i
by 1 plus i which we already know
is a rotation of 45 degrees
8 plus 2i times 1 plus i is equal to 8
plus 8i plus 2i plus 2i
squared since i squared is equal to
minus 1
that term becomes equal to minus 2 and
we end up with 6
plus 10i so walking along the path laid
out in the direction of 6
10 i will be an offset of 45 degrees
from the original path introducing
imaginary friends has given us
an extra dimension in which to travel
and a useful tool
for performing rotations these friends
might become a dime a dozen as you go on
in maths
but each one is still special
i'm proud of the friend who appears in
the wave function
of the electromagnetic wave the electric
field
and magnetic fields are perpendicular to
each other
and their magnitude and time variation
are correlated
by assigning the magnetic wave to the
imaginary part
and the electric wave to the real part
we can explain
these two waves in one equation
and capture the way that the sum of the
two individual waves
rotates
to meet some more imaginary friends head
over to brilliant
who have kindly sponsored this video
brilliant
is a place to learn in a fun and
challenging way
and while there you can meet my pals
julia
and mandelbrot in a course on complex
numbers
they will guide you through the rest of
the topic with visits to complex
multiplication
polar coordinates and the most beautiful
euler's formula it's great that you're
on youtube now
sparking your imagination by watching
math videos
but to solidify your knowledge as real
the best thing you can do
is to try problems for yourself
brilliance website
and app are built off the principle that
you learn best
while doing they have something for
everyone
so if you'd like to join me and a
community of 8 million
learners and educators today click the
link in the description
below or visit brilliant.org tibby's
safe travels to your imaginary world i
hope you have
and absolutely mathematical day
thank you to my patreon supporters and a
special mention
to today's patreon cat of the day mina
[Music]